well folks you know we get a lot of
questions about mutual funds and there's
a lot of bad information out there lies
mistakes call it whatever you want but
bad information out there for instance
have you heard the line that you might
as well buy an S&P index fund because
none of the growth stock mutual funds
outperform the S&P or a very very small
percentage I've heard one writer said
96% of the growth stock mutual funds do
not outperform the S&P another guy said
80% do not outperform the S&P and I've
seen these quotes floating around so
there's this whole thing called passive
investing meaning there's no sense in
trying to outperform the S&P 500 because
it can't be done if you don't know what
the S&P 500 is it's there's a company
called Standard & Poor s P that does
ratings on things around the stock
market and they write the top 500 stocks
the largest 500 companies on the New
York Stock Exchange which is the largest
companies publicly traded so an average
of those an index of those is called the
S&P 500 so pretty well is the stock
market the top 500 companies traded on
the New York Stock Exchange that is as
good a baseline of what the stock market
is doing as anything so if you invest in
the SP 500 you index funds you make
exactly what stock market makes no
better no worse and you can't beat that
anyway so you might as well just don't
win the towel even Warren Buffett came
out so the average person I'll just buy
index funds well I've got a real problem
with that because I own a whole bunch of
mutual funds then I'll perform the S&P
and it's really not rocket science to
find a fund that has outperformed the
S&P and so I was wondering how
many of these statistics are actually
true and I asked a couple of our smart
Wester pros to do some digging in the
actual database of mutual funds that are
out there and here's what we came up
with here's the real numbers total
large-cap funds in existence today that
were around 40 years ago so over the
last 40 years
there's 84 funds today open that are
large cap funds that have been around 40
years how many of those outperform the
S&P 30 a little over a third about 35%
of those 84 34 were actually growth
stock mutual funds straight up growth
stock mutual funds 34 were and how many
of those over 40 years outperformed the
S&P 13 so again about 40% about 60%
didn't okay so you can't quite flip a
coin and hit a mutual fund that
outperforms SMP but close it's almost a
50/50 see what I'm saying how about 30
years well over 30 years is 179 funds
out there
51 outperformed the S&P 70 were growth
and 27 of those outperformed the S&P so
again we're hovering in that 35 40
percent range what about over the last
20 years
well there's 446 funds out there that
have been performing for 20 years of
those how many outperformed the S&P 199
45% now 171 or growth funds how many of
those outperformed the S&P of the growth
funds 170 189 now we're up over 50% now
you can flip a coin and then hit one
that easy to find a mutual fund in the
last 20 years it's outperformed the S&P
500 last ten years nine hundred and
fifty seven funds out there
the
large cap funds and 247 of those
outperform the SP back down to about 35%
308 we're growth funds 153 of those
outperform the SP so in the last ten
years over 50% again right at 50%
naturally so you know 50 40 percent in
the 40 year 30 year 20 year 10 year
range about 40 to 50 percent of the
mutual funds of outperform the SMP that
means that half of them don't or over
half of them don't which is fine I got
no issue with that here's the thing my
point has always been you can get with a
smart Wester Pro and find a mutual fund
that is outperforming the SP in the
growth start mutual fund category and if
you can't you're an idiot I mean really
it is that hard you could blindfold a
monkey and he would throw a dart at a
board and hit a mutual fund half the
time a blindfolded monkey could could
half the time hit a mutual fund that
I'll perform the S&P
potami wouldn't but I'm gonna just
saying law that you say really
can you can you outperform this but yes
yes what Dave you can't make you know
you can't make 12% you can't your
portfolio doesn't outperform this pit
well I had them run my mutual funds the
ones that are in my 401k funds growth
growth and income aggressive growth
international growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international the
for funds we talk about putting a fourth
in each if you've done that over 40
years the S&P average annual return is
11.8% during that 40 years my mutual
funds performed at 13 point o4 as a
group so they beat it by a little more
than one and a quarter percent over 30
years my mutual funds at mix averaged
eleven point three SP averaged ten point
eight nine some B's about a half a point
their 20-year mix I made eight point
five three in the last 20 years average
and the SP made 7.1 - so my mix in my
personal 401k which is not rocket
science these are funds that everybody
in the mutual fund business knows about
they're really not hard to find across
the four things has outperformed the S&P
20 30 and 40 year track records I own
one fund that started in 1973 it is
average thirteen point four three
percent during that 44 years it has had
seven times it was down it is at thirty
seven times it was up I own another one
that is 83 years old 1934 average annual
return twelve point zero seven percent
number of down years during the 83 years
15 times it's been down the rest of time
it's been up 70 sometimes or 60
sometimes it's been up so I there's no
reason you can't be a millionaire
get on line and jump talk to one of
these smart investor pros and quit
reading this crap on the internet and
some of these stupid but books these
people are putting out this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]